[Música]
hola necesito que me presten su
imaginación por 30 segundos necesito que
se imaginen delante de ustedes una gran
bola metálica más grande que ustedes
mismos y muy muy pesado entonces la
tienen ahí intentan moverla le dan un
leve empujón y no se mueve está ahí
plantada a esta resistencia el
movimiento se la conoce como inercia por
lo que de ahora en adelante la
llamaremos la gran bola de inercia y
vengo yo y les plantea un desafío les
digo que si logran mover esta gran bola
de inercia unos metros adelante y la
depositan en el punto exacto van a
encontrar una llamada zona mágica antes
semejante oportunidad todos vamos a
decidir intentar probablemente al darse
cuenta del gran esfuerzo que esto
implica muchos decidan que no lo vale
tal vez se queden frustrados tal vez se
queden con curiosidad o tal vez
simplemente no les interesa conocer
tales son las mágicas pero estoy segura
que otra gran parte de nosotros va a
empujar con todo lo que tenga dentro y
eventualmente después de tanto esfuerzo
o empezar a moverse y cada vez va a
aceptar más y más el movimiento tanto
así que podemos empezar a correr
empujándola y necesito que aquí
reactiven su imaginación necesito que se
vean empujando que se vean corriendo en
el punto de parada a la vista y es
momento de parar pero como paramos y es
que la inercia no es simplemente la
resistencia el movimiento inercia es la
resistencia que pone que todo cuerpo a
cambiar de estado eso es lo que dijo
newton bueno tal vez no lo dijo
exactamente así pero me explico un poco
mejor un cuerpo en movimiento va a
querer seguir en movimiento mientras un
cuerpo en reposo a querer quedarse ahí
quieto en reposo a menos que apliquemos
sobre él la fuerza necesaria para
obligarlo a cambiar de estado
por lo que parada la gran bola de
inercia cuando ya la pusimos a hacer a
correr probablemente sea igual o más
difícil que poner la correa en primer
lugar por lo que nosotros los que
estamos ahí corriendo con todo
probablemente tampoco terminemos en el
lugar en el que nos esperábamos pero
bueno porque no ahora le cambiamos el
nombre a la gran bola de inercia por la
gran bola de la zona de confort cuanta
creen que es la inercia de su zona de
confort
bueno la respuesta obviamente va a
variar de persona a persona pero existe
un test genialmente escalofriante que
puede ayudar a determinar la y se llama
salto bungee hace aproximadamente un año
tuve la oportunidad de hacer el salto
bungee después de haberlo querido mucho
tiempo o pensar que lo quería pero bueno
les explico la hermenéutica del salto es
súper sencilla se suben en una pequeña
caja el instructor
la persona que va a saltar y alguien que
se sube para filmar todo por razones de
seguridad en lo que te van elevando a
los 120 metros de altura
el instructor te va dando todas las
pautas de cómo tirar su cuerpo para
adelante que tus pies
yo estaba lista para saltar
completamente aprobada y entonces
llegamos a la cima y es momento de
pararse afuera de la caja y al borde de
la plataforma con el día a una sujetando
t por el arnés y delante el vacío era
súper sencillo y me diría 321 lista yo
tenía que responder si levantar mis pies
entonces empezó 321 lista y no no no
estaba lista no había fuerza necesaria
en el mundo para mover la inercia que
sentían mis pies en ese momento los
saltos duraban aproximadamente 30
segundos el video de mi salto duraba
siete minutos con 36 segundos si se
podría decir que la inercia de mi zona
de confort en ese momento era 14 veces
mayor que la del promedio pero en fin en
esos eternos 7 minutos
el instructor pasó de ser un motivador
personal a apm que por favor ya salte a
amenazarme con que me bajaba y no me
devolvía en plata
de todo lo único que no quería hacer era
empujarme en nada pero en eso se le
iluminó y se le ocurrió el mejor consejo
me dijo que se vale los ojos y que los
abriera cuando el salto sea inevitable y
eso dice sobre los ojos y los abril
cuando volar sea inevitable pero mejor
les muestro un vídeo dejen de mostrar un
vídeo
[Música]
si bien
la zona de confort es fácil de explicar
con esto de los deportes extremos salir
de la zona de confort no se trata
exclusivamente de botar al vacío
hoy en día es más ha sido un concepto
muy adaptado por nuestra cultura de
popular pueden realizar una simple
búsqueda en google y les va a salir un
montón de contenido y les apuesto que la
primera frase que salta es la vida
comienza al final de tu zona de confort
pero es realmente tan horrible vivir en
este lugar antes de más por ver a qué
nos referimos cuando hablamos de zona de
confort
la zona de confort es un estado de
comportamiento neutro donde el individuo
se encuentra en un estado donde todo es
familiar y certero tenemos sentimiento
de pertenencia podemos definir bien
nuestra identidad nos sentimos cómodos y
competentes con lo que hacemos y suena
súper hermoso pero al mismo tiempo es
visto como una zona de estancamiento ya
que no existe ni crecimiento ni
aprendizaje entonces para todos esos en
las personas que no queremos vivir
estancadas que puede haber un poco más
allá para afuera de la zona de confort
se encuentra en la zona mágica en esta
zona el individuo se encuentra un estado
de incomodidad ya que a la vez alejarse
de lo familiar y al adentrarse en lo
desconocido
nos encontramos ante nuevas adversidades
y desafíos que nos fuerzan a tener
crecimiento y aprendizaje
suena super lindo pero hay una pequeña
trampa por afuera de nuestra zona mágica
aún queda una zona max la zona de pánico
y más que separada de la zona mágica por
una gran barrera y una puerta que dice
aquí entras a tu zona de pánico y una se
pararía por una pequeña línea punteada
muy fácil de cruzar y es en la zona de
pánico en el estado en el que empieza la
ansiedad el estrés y el miedo al
individuo ante la ante el gran cambio y
la falta de preparación para enfrentar
los nuevos desafíos empieza a tener
sentimientos de frustración la apatía
tristeza ansiedad estrés
es más o menos estar empujando tu bola
de la zona de confort a 1000 ya no tener
aliento y no poder parar
pero bueno aunque es una locura pensar
que hay personas que están viviendo así
yo me atrevo a decir que la gran mayoría
de nosotros se encuentra viviendo waka
waka
y podría ser una locura pensar que
vivimos así pero empecemos por ver un
poco de historia somos seres sedentarios
haciendo más de diez mil años antes de
la agricultura nosotros dependíamos de
nuestro cuerpo y de nuestras ideas para
sobrevivir a través de al tener calentar
alimentarnos a través de la casa y la
agricultura
de la casa y la recolección al volver
los agricultores nos asentamos y dejamos
de lado ese nómada viajero
más tarde con la revolución industrial y
con inventos como la pila eléctrica el
telégrafo la imprenta y la máquina de
vapor nuestros niveles de comodidad
aumentaron radicalmente
realmente el trabajo se volvió mucho más
fácil de lo que era y así llegamos a hoy
donde smart izamos todo lo que está a
nuestro paso para que un día no
necesitamos salir ni la ddi de la
comodidad de nuestro hogar y es más
creamos como una extensión de nuestro
cerebro para que un día ni siquiera
necesitemos pensar
hemos creado una bola tan o más grande
que la que nos imaginábamos hace un rato
y bueno antes de toda esta revolución de
la comodidad los humanos teníamos que
jugárnosla cada día cada día una nueva
adversidad un nuevo desafío un nuevo
clima entonces es posible que con toda
esta cara genética que llevamos más toda
la sobre motivación que nos llega de
todo el lado hoy en día nos encontremos
viviendo en un vaivén entre la zona de
confort y la zona de pánico que se ha
vuelto infinito y es que es verdad
cualquier persona que haya pasado por
eso puede admitir que hay algo de
adictivo en vivir la vida al borde de lo
imposible ya sea trabajando por ese loco
sueño subiendo el pico más alto de tu
ciudad comiendo esa maratón y
organizando ese evento
viajando con una mochila en la espalda y
sin presupuesto o cualquiera que sea ese
proyecto que te quito tantas horas de
vida y tantas horas de sueño
hay algo de adictivo en llegar al punto
de decir en que me he metido y salir de
esa comida parada tu bola de la zona de
confort para ponerla a correr nuevamente
y es que hoy me atrevo a decir que somos
muchos los que nos vivimos en un ciclo
de pánico a la zona de confort apenas
nos vemos limitados por lo límite de lo
que está que lo que es cómodo para
nosotros nos desesperamos y solo
queremos salir de ahí se nos ocurre la
nueva gran idea y nos metemos a eso con
todo de cabeza pero de cabeza caemos en
la zona de pánico y sea como sea lo
logramos no durmiendo tres días y eso no
lo recomiendo no lo hagan es peligroso o
cualquiera que sea su estado de pánico
lo logramos y salimos de ella pero ahí
nuestra zona de confort se expande y
otra vez nos sentimos cómodos nos
sentimos estancados
el ciclo infinito continua
y bueno vivir una vida así no es ni
sostenible ni estable ni mucho menos
económicamente viable así que qué
podemos hacer para no vivir estancados
pero tampoco abrumados
pues hay que balancear las fuerzas hay
que encontrar el equilibrio y no es
coincidencia que newton haya hecho su
primera ley sobre la inercia y la
segunda sobre el equilibrio y este
equilibrio no es quedarse estático un
cuerpo físicamente hablando puede
encontrarse en equilibrio y seguir el
movimiento y es este equilibrio nuestra
llamada zona mágica es poder es dejar el
ciclo infinito por empezar expandir
nuestra zona mágica de manera constante
y consciente y si suena súper hermoso
pero ya realmente prácticamente hablando
que podemos hacer podemos empezar con
tres simples cosas la primera día me
spoiler deja tu ego porque tener
ambición no está mal pero vivir como
esclavo de tu ego te va a llevar a tu
zona de pánico una tras otra tras otra
vez te lo aseguro
y es que hay que empezar por admitirlo
hay que empezar por darse cuenta de por
qué lo estás haciendo si lo estás
haciendo por cómo se va a ver tú en tu
cb o en tus redes sociales no vas a
llegar a tu zona mágica te lo aseguro si
sal de tu zona de confort pero hazlo por
ideas que sean más grande que tú mismo
que sean más grandes que tu ego ideas
que cuando te estés empujando a tu bola
de confort con todo permitan que el
miedo no te paralice
te permitan seguir avanzando
no comprometa su vida especialmente tu
salud y sé que esto cuando somos jóvenes
suena mentira porque podemos dormir
noches enteras vivir presos del estrés y
la ansiedad pero no es tan así y aquí
les canto una pequeña historia
imaginarse a una persona de 21 años que
quiere abarcar más de lo que es
humanamente posible duerme a las 5 de la
mañana porque sabrá terminar y responder
mails y se despierta a las 8 porque esa
hora tiene clases víctima del estrés y
la ansiedad por intentar alcanzar algún
estado de perfección viviendo en un
eterno estado de persecución y esa
persona era yo hace dos años cuando
salía electa presidenta del centro
estudiantes de universidad para hacer
una historia larga corta muchas personas
no creían que yo era capaz de hacerlo o
no me querían tanto entonces dejé me
dejé ser presa de mi ego y gracias por
querer lograr algún tipo de apreciación
social o poder querer llegar a las
expectativas de los demás
entre en las profundidades de mi zona de
pánico
y bueno comprometí mi vida y mi salud y
todo esto podría parecer que viene de
afuera pero realmente fui yo la que dejó
que eso me afecte a los 21 años de edad
me diagnosticaron pre diabetes del tipo
2 y sé que suena a drama pero realmente
lo mejor de todo esto es que no fue algo
peor y pasó a los tres meses de todo
esto ya que desde ese momento no es
ampliamente él porque lo estaba haciendo
y empecé a trabajar nuevamente por las
ideas que me llevaron a este lugar y no
porque los demás lo que los demás
esperaban que yo con quiera
y realmente fue este segundo tramo en el
que empecé a disfrutarlo y en el que
empecé a crecer y no les voy a mentir
esto enojó a muchas personas
en dirección porque tener ansiedad y
tener ganas de aprender cosas nuevas
siempre está bien pero nadie quiere
estar en 50 años dónde empezó hoy así
que si sal de tu zona de confort pero
con dirección y con metas claras para
que cuando estés cuando estés en 30 años
más adelante puedes mirar atrás y darte
cuenta cuánto creciste
y es que bueno realmente no se le puede
hacer justicia con palabras al
sentimiento de estar logrando algo que
está muy por fuera del alcance bueno que
tú creías que está muy por fuera de tu
alcance ya sea intelectual o físico es
literalmente mágico es estar a 5 mil
metros de altura ideas y ver esa vista
que hace que te olvides cuando te olían
tus pies o cuando te faltaba el aliento
y bueno ya sea que estés en tu zona de
confort o en tu zona de pánico o en un
eterno ir y venir entre ambas no te
rindas y si ve atrás tu zona mágica sólo
tienes que se van los ojos balancear tus
fuerzas y vencer a la inercia de tu zona
de confort gracias
[Aplausos]